- [Instructor] We are told
to write seven hundredths
as a fraction and a decimal.
Why don't you get some
paper and a pencil out
and see if you can do that
before we do it together.
All right, so let's do
it first as a fraction.
So what is going to be the
denominator of our fraction
if they're saying seven hundredths?
And the way I'm saying it
is a little bit of a hint.
Seven hundredths, oh, I
think you got the picture.
We're dealing with hundredths.
So our denominator is going to be 100.
And then how many hundredths do we have?
Well we have seven of them.
I'll do that in a different
color just to be clear.
We have seven of those hundredths.
So there you have it, seven hundredths.
That's this expressed as a fraction.
Now what about as a decimal?
Well, we could think
about our decimal places.
If let's say that this is the ones place,
and I'm just putting a little blank here.
So this is the ones place,
and you have a decimal right over here.
And then this would be the tenths place.
And then this would be
the hundredths place.
Well we have, we want to
represent seven hundredths.
So let me be clear, this
right over here is ones.
This is tenths, and this is hundredths.
I like saying, it's unusually
fun to say that, hundredths.
All right, ones, tenths, hundredths.
So how many ones do we have here?
Well we have no ones, we have zero ones.
How many tenths do we have here?
Well we have no tenths.
How many hundredths do we have?
Well we have seven hundredths.
Okay now it's getting annoying.
We have seven hundredths.
So you can write it that way as well.
And if I wanted to just write
it a little bit cleaner,
I could just write no ones, no
tenths, and seven hundredths.
I said it the last time
like a normal person.
Let's do another example.
Here, we're told select the
written form of each number.
And so they, on the left right over here,
you have different representations here.
We have things written
as a decimal, a fraction,
another decimal, and
then we want to say hey,
which of these are represented in words
or a combination of
numbers and words up here.
So pause this video and
have a go at this as well.
Okay, so this first
number right over here,
we have no ones, and
then as we go one space
to the right of the decimal,
this is the tenths place.
And it's clear we have
four of those tenths.
So this right over here is four tenths.
So that is this choice
right here, so we would,
I'll shade it in, if you're
doing this on Khan Academy,
you would just click there
and it would fill in.
So what about this one?
Well this one, we would read,
you have four out of ten, or four tenths.
So this again would be four tenths.
So we would shade that one in.
Now what's going on over here?
We have no ones, we have no tenths.
But we have four hundredths.
I said it again, it's too much fun.
So we have four hundredths.
So that's this column.
So we would fill that
one in, and we're done.